[Música]
es un gusto saludarlos Soy Paula Jiménez
Correa y les doy la bienvenida Así es
Asia el magazine quincenal de France 24
que aborda las múltiples realidades de
este continente Estos son nuestros
titulares
el parlamento de Indonesia aprobó una
polémica modificación al código penal
que incluye la prohibición del sexo
fuera del matrimonio y la cohabitación
entre parejas no casadas muchas
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
consideran que es un retroceso en las
libertades civiles
en China el gobierno anunció un
relajamiento las restricciones por el
Coby 19 cuarentenas en casa y la
eliminación de pruebas pcr para ingresar
a lugares públicos son algunas de las
medidas que empiezan a ver los
ciudadanos
las cifras por muertes de migrantes
nepaleces que trabajaron en las
construcciones para el mundial de Qatar
son escalofriantes según el gobierno de
nepal de 13.000 Trabajadores al menos
dos mil fallecieron principalmente por
caídas o ataques al corazón ongs
aseguran que estos números son mayores
iniciamos nuestro recorrido por el
continente asiático en Indonesia el
parlamento aprobó la reforma el código
penal que castigará con prisión a las
parejas que cohabiten y tengan sexo sin
casarse así como musulmanes que
renuncian al islam y a ciudadanos que
insulten al presidente la nueva ley
generó protestas de varios grupos lgbtiq
más y organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
Samuel Salgado nos amplía
el sexo y la cohabitación extramarital
serán castigados con cárcel en Indonesia
la decisión fue aprobada por unanimidad
en el parlamento indonesio y entrará en
vigor en un plazo máximo de tres años
así lo anunciaba el ministro de Justicia
quien recordó que esta ley es una
herencia colonial
tras el largo debate Esperamos que la
gente entienda que hemos hecho todo lo
posible por acomodarnos a las
aspiraciones de los ciudadanos y hemos
debatido todas las cuestiones
importantes en las que nuestras
opiniones estaban divididas
la reforma del Código Penal establece un
año de prisión para las parejas que
tengan relaciones sexuales sin casarse y
para aquellas que cohabiten sin la unión
marital la condena será de seis meses
como se supervisará quien incumple la
ley los cónyuges padres e hijos serán
los encargados de denunciar a quien
infrinja y los extranjeros no estarán
exentos de cumplir ya que la ley también
se aplicará para ellos esto encendió las
alarmas de algunos turistas que suelen
visitar la icónica isla de Bali en el
sur del país y podría afectar
económicamente al sector hotelero a su
vez algunos indonesios se manifestaron
frente al parlamento
aprobaron una ley que no es democrática
controla nuestras vidas privadas y no se
preocupa de los asuntos públicos en 2019
los indonesios se habían manifestado en
contra del intento de instaurar el nuevo
Código Penal que también castiga la
apostasía y los insultos al presidente
yokowidodo obligando al ejecutivo a
suspender su aprobación sin embargo tres
años después se aprobó y regirá en el
país con más musulmanes en el mundo
[Música]
Nos dirigimos a China desde hace algunos
días el gobierno de
xii ha empezado a relajar las
restricciones por covid-19 entre las
medidas más destacadas se encuentran
permitir hacer la cuarentena en casa y
no en hospitales o centros de
aislamiento y eliminar el requisito de
presentar una prueba pcr negativa para
ingresar a lugares públicos y el
transporte se trata de un cambio
dramático en la política de cero covid
que generó una ola de manifestaciones en
varias ciudades de china en las que
incluso se llegó a exigir la renuncia
del presidente
Pero qué más hay detrás de esta
flexibilización a la política de cero
covid le trasladamos esta pregunta a
Carlos berismo storage periodista
internacional y experto en temas de
china
hoy lo que estamos teniendo es una
visión que difiere mucho de lo que
podría ser una política de salud o de un
gobierno interesado con la salud
en China está enfrentando ya hace 15
meses una crisis inmobiliaria de
importancia se cree que un 30% de la
economía de China está afectada por esta
crisis inmobiliaria que hoy tiene una
reducción de un 16 17 hasta un 20% de en
cuanto a lo que son las inversiones Cómo
Qué pasó en este caso seis bancos
cerraron y se quedaron con sus depósitos
de alguna forma retenidos para con la
gente Pero además algunas corporaciones
inmobiliarias muy grandes como Ever
grande que es uno de los grandes
colapsos en la economía inmobiliaria
china le dieron un panorama muy muy Din
todo esto por qué Dinámico porque
algunas familias que tenían inversiones
puestas ahí también quedaron sujetas de
esto hay que ver que china además tuvo
algunos problemas como lo tuvo el mundo
en cuanto a la guerra el problema de la
de la falta de suministros Y en especial
lo que es hoy
la sequía a nivel mundial que afectó
también China qué ha dado todo esto ha
dado una baja muy importante en lo que
es la producción ha dado una baja muy
importante lo que es el empleo y
fundamentalmente en la tasa de
crecimiento hoy china en vez de crecer a
tasas chinas va a crecer según el Banco
Mundial al Dos punto ocho lo que es en
otros países podría ser considerado
correcto pero para china es un gran
problema el desempleo está hoy por hoy
en un 5 6% pero la tasa para los jóvenes
que son justamente los que más
manifiestan este sería superior estaría
en este caso en un 16 17% algunos hablan
de un 19% en todo esto las protestas
vistas recientemente en las calles de
varias ciudades del país no tienen
precedentes Además del hartazgo social
por los constantes confinamientos hay
algo más detrás de estas movilizaciones
esto nos dijo nuestro invitado
la protesta se empezaron realmente en en
yin yang que es uno de las poblaciones
de orden musulmán importantes en más de
una más de una oportunidad vimos
denuncias para con ellos
En definitiva un millón un millón y
medio de personas habían sido recluidas
y no podían salir
esa misma esas mismas personas sufrieron
un accidente lamentable un incendio Y
eso detonó manifestaciones pero esas
manifestaciones no se dieron solo en la
en esta etnia que es la etnia musulmana
que por otra parte
sufrió una transformación de sus lugares
de rezo en oficinas O fábricas eso es
algo muy interesante de pensarlo uno vio
como que estas manifestaciones se fueron
dando o escalando a nivel de todo china
no podemos pensar que estamos frente a
lo que sucedió en tianamen pero tenemos
que pensar de que esa dispersión tan
grande tiene que tener algún otro tipo
de relación la verdad es que la
población china está cansada de estar
recluida por el tema covid está cansada
de los testeos compulsivos eso le quita
posibilidades de poder visitar salir
tener una vida totalmente normal están
con problemas realmente graves en cuanto
a los suministros hay carteles en China
que hablan de no queremos tanto testeo
sino que queremos más comida son
situaciones que históricamente no las
habíamos vivido en décadas para con
chile los constantes confinamientos han
hecho incluso pensar que las vacunas
chinas no han sido tan efectivas como se
pensaba tiene esto alguna relación para
que se mantuviera por mucho tiempo la
política serocovit y que viene para el
país esto nos dijo nuestro analista
entre otras cosas chinas uno de los
grandes fabricantes de vacunas ha
vacunado de casi que hay un 90% de la
población china que es asintomática eso
está un problema por eso es el testeo
tan importante ha vacunado
mayoritariamente a todos no a las
personas mayores lo que llama
poderosamente la atención
hoy parecería que todo el mundo
relacionado al tema de la salud va por
otro lado Paula porque En definitiva Uno
ve las propias manifestaciones que se
están dando en en base a ciertos
conceptos que en el mundo occidental
sería imposible de pensar hoy china
controla las redes sociales de todos una
cosa llamada el arco dorado y donde ve
que hay mucho tráfico de información que
no es correcta para con el régimen
justamente en esos lugares y justamente
los lugares donde el desempleo empezó a
aumentar porque las empresas se han ido
de China es donde empiezan a ver
reclusiones por el tema del covid hay
que ver que es muy importante también
que una persona que manifiesta en China
es un muerto civil Ya que él pierde todo
el sistema de puntaje social puntaje que
te amerita escribirte facultades usar
los trenes públicos hacer algunos
trámites en la administración pública
apertura de cuentas etcétera etcétera o
sea los manifestantes en China no solo
reciben una reprimenda sino que hay una
reprimenda social de atrás de todo esto
situación que es imposible pensar en el
mundo occidental qué va a ocurrir en el
futuro bueno
ha relajado un poco los confinamientos
ha relajado un poco lo que sería la
política de de de reclusión por el pero
no lo pensemos que es solo por un tema
de salud él necesita que estas empresas
como lo fue Apple ahora que se está
yendo como lo es Adidas vuelvan a
invertir agradecemos a Carlos bellísimo
estorage por su análisis en otros temas
miles de trabajadores nepaleces han
muerto en Qatar desde 2010 en las obras
de construcción de varias estructuras
para el mundial de fútbol pero las
víctimas rara vez reciben una
compensación por parte de las empresas
cataríes debido a la alta tasa de
desempleo y los bajos salarios medio
millón de nepaleses deciden ir a
trabajar a países del Golfo y Malasia
quedando atrapados en lo que se conoce
como la esclavitud moderna
en el Aeropuerto Internacional de
katmandú este hombre regresa de Qatar
con el ataúd de su colega y amigo ambos
estaban como trabajadores de la
construcción para varios lugares de la
Copa del Mundo
de 35 años murió al caer de un andamio
estaba trabajando en el sitio de
construcción también trabajo en Qatar
para la misma empresa estábamos
trabajando Cuando ocurrió el accidente
ayude a traer su cuerpo de vuelta a
nepal tiene esposa e hijos padres y un
hermano menor cada día 500 personas
hacen fila aquí en el centro de Visas de
Qatar como suero de 31 años
encontró trabajo como manipulador de
equipaje con un salario de 300 euros al
mes que es tres veces el salario
promedio en nepa tengo que aceptar este
tipo de trabajo porque tengo que
alimentar a los nueve miembros de mi
familia los nepalíes son el principal
grupo de trabajadores migrantes en las
sedes de la Copa del Mundo la extrema
pobreza de la región obliga a la gente a
dar este paso drástico corriendo el
riesgo no volver jamás dejando a sus
familias en una mayor angustia como
samita y sus hijos Hace seis meses su
esposo murió en doha en uno de los
lugares de construcción de uno de los
estadios de la Copa del Mundo tenía 31
años
Ese es mi esposo
llevaba tres años trabajando allí la
pareja esperaba un futuro mejor para su
hija y su hijo
se fue el extranjero para que pudiéramos
construir nuestra propia casa pero
después de cuatro meses murió
Nos quedamos sin nada
solo un papel que dice que mi esposo
murió de un infarto cada vez que muera
un trabajador nepalía en Qatar la causa
de la muerte dada es casi siempre la
misma un ataque al corazón lo cual se
cataloga como una muerte natural esto
exime a las empresas de pagar
indemnizaciones a los familiares de las
víctimas una tasa de mortalidad a tan
alta de trabajadores entre 20 y 40 años
es muy alarmante para este médico el
gobierno no permite que ningún
trabajador Viaje al extranjero sin antes
pasar un examen médico completo los
infartos afectan principalmente a
personas mayores de 50 años pero los que
se van al extranjero son en su mayoría
jóvenes Esta es la principal
preocupación el gobierno del nepal
Debería ser algo al respecto
es difícil saber el número exacto de
muertes según el gobierno de nepal casi
13.000 lepalías trabajaron en los
distintos lugares de la Copa del Mundo
incluidos estadios hoteles aeropuertos y
carreteras entre ellos al menos 2000
nepalíes perdieron la vida según los
datos oficiales para las organizaciones
de Derechos Humanos el número de Muertos
del gobierno está muy subestimado los
nepalíes ahora se dirigen a Arabia
Saudita que albergará los Juegos
Olímpicos de invierno en 2029
y para el cierre les dejo estos datos de
acuerdo con la unidad de inteligencia
económica cinco de las ciudades más
costosas del mundo este 2022 se
encuentran en Asia en primer lugar se
encuentra Hong Kong en el quinto lugar
Tokio la capital de Japón en el octavo
lugar se ubica Shanghai en el noveno
quanshu estas dos últimas son ciudades
chinas en el décimo lugar se ubica seúl
la capital de Corea del Sur
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es Asia Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
las redes sociales que aparecen en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
de nuestra página web trans24.com Hasta
pronto
[Música]